you and Aaron Paul have great chemistry
on thank you the show and it is intense
it is intense it is so intense when we
play a couple that's that's kind of
going through some marital problems and
as intense as those scenes are we are
actually really quite unprofessional at
times and we break out into fits of
laughter really why you're because you
know when I are watching a scene like
that we're thinking it must be like a
church on the set because it's so
intense but just knowing Aaron Paul he
comes by all the time you know that
really yeah to be like that all the time
you're gonna be like that okay yeah yeah
no we I'm always honestly surprised when
I see the scenes
I cut together and they're edited so
well because we I guess we're in the
middle of a scene and we're crying and
I'm looking at Aaron Paul and I'm like
wow I'm bawling with Aaron Paul and then
you just have to like wonder the
absurdity and and because because you're
constantly breaking up laughing yeah I
think I think because we're just being
so vulnerable yeah and I just and what
we're doing it kind of feels very true
and then I think oh my god it's so
ridiculous and then we and then we waste
everybody's time for like 20 minutes and
everybody goes and takes a leak and has
a coffee and then we just sort of become
adults finally finally they could you
see I guess what that is a testament to
is how much you can accomplish with
editing yeah for example you know we
take the show a little before it airs
yeah when our Anthony Anderson interview
airs it's going to be the most prim and
proper interview I'm sad to see him go I
had a few questions for him so well
Andy and I have been around the block a
few times
you